do that but actions like that Iran took
are not only destabilizing but
um
they fly in the face of the the
rules-based order that we are seeking to
uphold yeah follow up sure so I don't
understand how my question is
hypothetical it's a public
statement by a U.S official that quote
respond through appropriate means
unquote
what are appropriate means in this
instance well I'm not going but you're
you're the way you had phrased it I
believe at first was if this happens
then or what further actions take well
let me just say that I again
I'm not going to forecast what means
we're going to take I don't think that
would be a
good I don't think it'd be a good way to
show our cards uh from here I think
um
I would let Mr Sullivan's statements
stand for itself
um again we are going to work with our
partners and allies and we continue to
work with our partners and allies in the
region
um and you know I'm not gonna I'm not
just gonna go down a path of like
potentially
telling you what we could or could not
do I just don't think that's helpful at
this time
this incident been discussed during the
phone call today between the secretary
and his Israeli counterpart we'll have a
readout shortly and from there you can
see what was discussed yeah anyone else
here
yes
Russia I have a couple of questions if I
may okay thank you my first question is
about yesterday's press briefing
General Milly said that he tried to
reach his Russian counterparts it's
called the incident in Poland but it was
unsuccessful and so my question is what
would you want to accomplish with this
call what what was the idea I would
direct you to a staff
okay and my second question is about
arms inspections in Ukraine are there
any findings already or are they still I
have nothing to read out at this time
when I do I'll let you know okay anyone
else yeah Clinton Clark from the
Australian Broadcasting Corporation it's
really nice to see you in the briefing
room thank you it's the first time yeah
okay well Australia has been struck by a
couple of pretty major cyber attacks
recently one emanating it appears from
Russia I'm just wondering have you had
is the defense department had any
communication with Australia about those
attacks and would you see such an attack
at the moment it's hard to see whether
or not there's speculation about whether
or not it's been
not orchestrated but at least with the
some sort of Russian government okay
would you see a similar attack in
America as being an attack by a foreign
entity and how how would you see such an
attack in Australia well in terms of an
attack on Australia again
cyber attacks are incredibly dangerous
we have here from
on from the Department other agencies
have worked with Australian counterparts
and continue to work with them I don't
have a call to read out from the
secretary per se but of course we are in
touch at different levels with the
Australian government in terms of your
second question I just want to can you
repeat I just want to make sure I'm
understanding it correctly it is now
um Australia Australia's trying to
analyze exactly what this attack meant
who's behind it would you see a similar
attack in this case it was Australian
private information being taken help for
ransom and although there is no direct
evidence at least publicly that it was
orchestrated by the Russian government
if a similar attack occurred in the
United States where people from Russia
for example or another country were
taking that kind of information would
you see that as being effectively an
attack on America by a foreign country
well again that's a hypothetical
fortunately that it's not that has not
happened and I'm not going to engage in
hypotheticals from here but I thank you
for the question but just not going to
get into that
um okay yes I'll take one more and then
I'll wrap it up thank you so much with
the recent uh crane forces that the
chief that they did against the Russian
forces so does the dod think that
Ukraine today is in a position of
strength to start a negotiation with
Russia
well I would again and I think the
secretary and the chairman spoke to this
it is up to Ukraine to decide when they
want to negotiate uh
the secretary uh you know convened the
Ukraine contact group yesterday to work
with our partners and allies around the
world to ensure that Ukraine has what it
needs in this war against Russia and you
know just to remind folks here but this
war could end tomorrow uh this war could
end now Russia has the opportunity the
choice to make uh to decide to pull its
troops to remove its equipment to get
its systems out of Ukraine and
um and you know be held responsible for
invading a Sovereign Nation and so
you know I I would let Ukraine
um speak to when it's ready uh to to
negotiate but I think you heard pretty
strongly from the secretary and from the
chairman yesterday that
um we are we are committed to providing
Ukraine what it needs and we are going
to continue to provide Ukraine what it
needs for the Long Haul okay great
thanks all um happy Friday Thursday
happy Thursday
and I will see you tomorrow
yes yeah